Is my screen visible?
Yes ma'am.
Okay fine.
So first of all, what we have to do is
the part of discussion today
will be transport setup
and the concession groups
which are created in the system.
This is your interface, login
system.
So first of all
whenever we have to do
transport setup, where is our
basic transport setup option?
Let's see, basic transport setup.
What do you have?
Here are the settings.
You must have noticed
that our basic setup is
in the settings icon.
They depend on which
section you are doing
and they will access that section and do the basic setup.
What we have to do today is the basic setup of transport.
What will be in the basic setup of transport?
For example, there is an institute.
Which buses are there in that institute?
Which pick up points are being considered in that bus?
Like there is a bus
which bus goes to which pick up points?
Where are the drop points of the student?
So that data
which we are managing
which pick up point is assigned to a student
which drop point is assigned to a student
which bus is assigned to a student.
To do that, we have to give a basic configuration
to the system.
Like this is the number of buses in the institute.
These are the points in each bus.
These are the charges in the bus
which we will set up basically.
The point is clear. What do we have to discuss?
Bhavya Tanvi.
Yes ma'am.
So how will we do it?
You have the option to set up the institute.
In this we have
an option of transport.
Whatever is the basic setup of transport
the first level setup of every session
we do it from here.
Remember one more thing.
The transport is
session dependent.
Session dependent means what?
Can anyone tell us?
Session dependent is the transport.
Session dependent.
Like session wise
like if we switch the session
then
means
the students' promote
whatever we have to set up
they are session dependent.
Ok.
Bhavya, do you know the meaning of session dependent?
Yes ma'am.
Session dependent means
very simple.
Like every session
the setup will be different.
So we will call it session dependent.
So you will go to transport.
Here you have the option.
First is vehicle.
Then there is vehicle route.
In that institute
the number of buses
the detail of each bus
is your vehicle.
You will click on it.
Ok.
Here you have the super option.
New vehicle.
I know I have this entity.
Bus 1, bus 2, bus 3
I have the details of their RC numbers.
So how to add a bus?
You will click on new vehicle.
Then you have a window open.
What is this for?
The entries of the bus
are the details.
You have to enter the details of the bus.
First comes RC number.
Like HR 0123
is the number.
You can enter that.
I am putting a simple one.
Then after that
how many seating capacity is there in this bus?
Like 50 seating capacity,
50 seats, 80 seats, 100 seats.
Total seats.
Then your tank capacity.
This is not mandatory.
Full tank capacity, GPS ID.
This is for GPS tracking.
We provide a facility
like this.
I am giving you a brief introduction.
What facility is that?
In which it is used.
We provide an option
like GPS track option.
Means student epic.
QR code kind of.
It will scan the child.
It will get the attendance of the child.
We provide an option of GPS tracker.
GPS is in the bus.
It puts the ID here.
It is not mandatory.
This is your mandatory field.
RC number, your seating capacity.
Then its insurance date,
amount of insurance company.
Rest is your non-mandatory
information.
The corresponding information
of the vehicle.
This is your information.
If you start adding this
it will give you the mandatory information.
Insurance date.
Like I am taking this for now.
For example
the insurance of this bus
is from 2 to 8.
Then the insurance date will come.
After that if you have a corresponding document
you can update it.
Same pollution certificate,
fitness certificate, road permit, road tax.
So we have a vehicle
corresponding mandatory information and documents.
We save that in the data.
Clear?
Now I am just adding
random data.
Here you will get the option
to add the vehicle.
In the same way you can
create N number of vehicles in the system.
You have added the vehicle
Still you have to update it.
You can do this.
You have to update
more information.
You have the option
to update the detail.
You can update the existing detail as well.
Then you have the option
to update the data.
Any doubts?
No ma'am.
Is it clear?
One minute.
Ok.
Let's continue.
Is this part clear?
Yes ma'am.
This is your vehicle
that you add.
You can add bus 1 and bus 2.
Now
what we have done is
we have added the data
of buses in the transport
institute.
Now in that bus
where the bus is going,
where it drops the students,
where it picks them,
all that is our vehicle route.
Do you understand the route?
The whole route of a bus
is defined in the system
in the vehicle route.
Ok.
How do we create this?
You have the option
of new vehicle route, copy from session
and then exit.
What option do we have?
It is possible that
there are many entities
that are running from the previous session.
Ok.
The previous session
means
that the previous session
has the same data.
It means that you have to copy
from the previous session.
So we can use this feature
which is the button
to copy from the previous session.
This will be used
because you will have a session list.
This entity has a single session.
If it had only 24-25 entities,
it would have come in the drop-down.
If I had selected that,
the set-up of the vehicle route
would have been copied from the previous session.
Do you understand the purpose of this?
Yes ma'am.
We have also done the BAP module
in the basic set-up,
copy from the previous session.
Yes, so you can copy from the previous session
if you have any previous
already existing entity.
Now I have a new entity
in which I have to add the vehicle route.
What is this Excel?
The data that you have here
is to export that data in Excel.
We will add a new vehicle route.
You have the option
to add it.
Now you have to add the name of the route.
For example,
I have added route 1.
Which vehicle is running on the first route?
The whole list will come here.
The data that I will give you
if you create N number of vehicles,
the whole list will come here.
You can set the route according to yourself.
Like the bus that runs on route 1,
which bus runs,
I have selected that vehicle.
Then,
you have to understand
what this means.
In the case of school,
installments are made
in case it is monthly.
You must have seen it in your fee structure.
In case it is not monthly,
it is bi-monthly.
For example,
there is one for 6 months.
It will be from April to June.
It will be for 6 months.
So all the installments are made.
This is how it is in school.
We get it.
Now, you have to add the pick-up points here.
Like, this bus
that runs on route 1,
for example,
it is going on Ansal,
at Tehsil camp,
it has some pick-up points.
For example, this is Ansal's pick-up point.
But
as far as the fees are concerned,
the pace of our installments
will not cost us.
Select skip installment, we have to skip the transport amount for the selected particular
installment.
Ma'am, we can select multiple months at a time.
Exactly, we can select for the first or second installment, but keep in mind that he will
skip.
Selecting means that he will not put the last piece in that particular installment.
We do this in the case of schools, we select the month of June, then when we assign a particular
pick-up point to the student, then in that case, it will take place from April to March
and it will not take place in June because we have selected the month of June.
This is the main agenda.
Then we have the select employee.
Now, you can also assign the driver of this bus.
You can assign more than one.
Now, where does this data come from?
It comes from the employee.
In our setup, you have not seen the basic employee of HRM.
Have you seen how the employees are added?
No, I have not seen it.
Okay.
So now when you see it, you will know.
Basic employees are added.
All the employees of the institute, either teaching, non-teaching, driver, daily wages,
whatever, we also save their data, so they come to the employee.
Means this is the driver of the bus, its list comes, the list is created in your system.
Okay?
Is it clear?
Yes ma'am.
Okay.
Now we come to the pick-up point.
Like I have this bus.
In this bus, where does this bus go?
On the side of the institute, we have complete data in an excel format.
Complete data comes.
Their complete data will be there.
It will be written in route 1.
This vehicle runs.
And this vehicle runs in route 1.
What are the pick-up points in this?
I call it Ansel.
Okay?
If Ansel has a pick-up point, what is the pick-up time?
What is the drop time?
Like this bus is running.
At what time does this bus reach Ansel?
At what time does it drop the students at Ansel?
Okay?
That is the timing.
For example, I put it at 6 am.
Okay?
And what is my drop point?
4 pm.
Okay?
This is the pick-up time and drop point.
The drop time will be there.
Okay?
Then after that, you have the amount.
Longitude and latitude are not mandatory.
In which case does this work?
I told you that our GPS tracking system works.
Okay?
So we put the longitude and latitude of the bus.
It is of Google Maps.
That means it is not in use case.
You will know it slowly.
Okay?
Basically, we put this.
Then its amount, its corresponding Ansel route, how much is it?
For example, 2000.
Okay?
So this is 2000.
Same.
Add another pick-up point.
Similarly, you can add number of pick-up points.
Now we will add one.
You will add.
As soon as you add, it will be created in the system.
Okay?
This option, this was the option to manually add the pick-up route.
In the pick-up route, all the pick-up points are there.
If you put only one pick-up point, that is why it is being made here.
If you put more than one, it will be more than one.
Is that okay?
Let's move ahead.
There are more options in this.
Yes, ma'am.
Okay?
You have added it once, but it can be like this.
Later, you have to add more pick-up points in it.
In that case, there is the same option of plus edit.
You will edit.
The interface will open.
You will add another according to you.
You will update.
It will be updated.
Okay?
That means you can add multiple points.
Yes, exactly.
And you can add number of points here.
Okay.
One is done.
Then you will add pick-pick.
Then you will add another.
Okay.
This was our option to add manually till now.
Means you can manually add buttons in the system.
Then there is an option.
You can also update it in bulk via Excel.
Okay?
That will be our option.
Upload pick-up point.
This will be our sample Excel.
This is only because we have added one pick-up point in it.
It is not for root.
You will have to make a root from the musical root.
We create a kind of roadmap.
We can add all the points in it with this.
It has sample Excel.
Let me show you.
Remember one more thing.
With sample Excel, we don't have in-time and out-time mandatory.
Means this is pick-up time, pick-up time and out-drop time.
This is non-mandatory.
But if we add manually, it will take time from us.
Excel is not mandatory.
Okay?
Same thing.
There is a name of pick-up point.
There is amount.
There is time.
Whatever you are adding there manually, you can keep it in Excel format.
As it is, once you upload Excel, it will be done.
Excel format is very simple.
There is pick-up point, amount, pick-up time and drop latitude.
Okay?
If you have any doubts, tell me in Excel.
No, ma'am.
Okay.
Then let's look ahead.
This will be uploaded from Excel.
Okay?
Here you will choose a file.
Whatever you will save.
Okay.
Do you understand Excel?
How to do it?
You have kept data in Excel.
Whatever you update.
Okay?
You have saved it in your system.
After saving, you will access it from here.
You will choose a file.
It will be saved in your system.
It will be accessed from there.
It will be accessed.
Then you will click on submit.
It will update the data.
In case if it doesn't update, if there is an issue, it will generate an error file and
give it to you.
If it gets an error.
What can be the error?
Like you have not added the metadata information.
You have left the amount blank.
Or you have added an amount.
Okay?
In that case, it will give you an error.
Clear?
Yes, ma'am.
If you want to export the data of the existing data, you can do it in Excel.
Your existing data.
This is our basic transport setup.
If you have any doubts, you can tell us.
Let's move ahead.
Not yet.
Okay.
Then, the third option is transport Excel upload.
What does this option mean?
We have defined the configuration in the system.
The number of buses.
The road map of the bus.
We have defined that.
Now, which student has to go in which bus?
Which student goes through which pickup point?
That is what we have defined.
Okay?
For that, we have the same two options.
You are assigning a bus to a student manually.
Okay?
Or you have Excel.
You have some data of Excel.
You assign all the students to Excel.
Okay?
So, if we have to assign data of transport from Excel to students, then we have this
option.
Transport Excel upload.
Okay?
Is the meaning clear?
Why is it being used?
Repeat it once.
What have we done in the system?
We have defined the buses of the institute.
We have set up which bus goes to which pickup point and which drop point.
We have not assigned a student to which pickup point and which bus goes to which.
We have not assigned that.
Okay?
When we have to assign data from Excel, then we have this option.
Transport Excel upload.
It has student details.
Basically, the routes are assigned to the student.
Yes, exactly.
We are assigning the route to the student.
This is also your sample.
I will show it to you.
This is our sample.
Okay?
It will be visible.
Yes, ma'am.
Here, you will have a reg number.
You must have noticed something in ERP.
The student that we consist in ERP, we look at it with a unique ID.
That is reg number.
We can also say over admission number.
It depends on what word we are using in the institute.
Reg number is a unique ID for the student.
We update all the data corresponding to it.
Either it is the transport, or the student's fee demand,
or why it doesn't have any existing details.
The student details that we update.
We do a reg number corresponding to it.
We are doing the same in this too.
The student's reg number comes here.
Which student is it?
It must be his reg number.
Okay?
Then, it's wickle root and pick-up point.
What is wickle root?
Here, we make the wickle root.
This is the wickle root.
This is the name.
This is our wickle root.
Then, it's pick-up point.
Which pick-up point will it be?
Which pick-up point is it coming from?
Like Ansel.
Here, I have made another one.
Like the seal camp.
Which sector is it coming from?
In this way, pick-up points are different.
Which pick-up point is it coming from?
It is coming from root 1.
So, what will I keep in Excel?
I will keep root 1.
The student's reg number will be the student's.
Then, your wickle root.
That is root 1.
And then, its pick-up point.
What is the pick-up point?
That is Ansel.
So, I will keep Ansel here.
In case of any other student's pick-up point,
I will keep someone else.
Okay.
If there is some other root,
I will keep that root.
Do you understand?
So, this is the root point.
We will just assign this.
So, automatically, in the student's interface,
the corresponding fees that we have created here
will be charged to the office.
Okay.
Is there no need for wickle number in Excel?
No.
Why is there no need for wickle number?
Because we are defining wickle number in this.
In Excel, the root
and its corresponding pick-up point
will be needed.
Okay.
So, in that case, you will get this.
Means, the simple purpose of this point
is that you are assigning
the data of transport
to the students via Excel.
Okay, ma'am.
Okay.
Then, we have to discuss
one thing.
This was our basic transport setup.
Okay.
We will discuss one more thing today.
That is, concession books.
You must have seen
this basic fee setup
How does it work?
How do fee heads,
term group,
and fee group work?
Up to here,
it must have been okay.
From fee heads to fee group.
It is okay.
Okay.
Now, we will discuss
one point today.
That is, concessions.
Look.
What do we have?
There is an entity.
There is an institute.
In the institute,
there are many concessions.
Like sibling concession.
You must have heard about it.
Apart from that,
there is staffer concession.
If a student is a teacher's child,
then a staffer concession is given to him.
There is third child concession.
Like, if there are three siblings,
then a third concession is given to one of them.
Right?
So, in this way,
there can be many concession groups
in the system.
So, in the system,
concession groups have to be created.
That is the concession option.
Same.
Now, you can understand that
concession is also session dependent.
Right?
Session to session,
it varies.
Or you can copy according to yourself.
The existing session of last year,
the same concession of that session
will also be there.
You can copy it
and create as it is.
Okay?
Yes, ma'am.
Okay.
Now, how to add a new concession
in the system?
You have the option
to add a new concession group.
Now, look, how does this come?
In the system,
whatever fee you have defined,
and the corresponding installments,
because your entire fee structure
is going according to the installment.
Okay?
So, even the concession
will not be given according to the installment.
Like, if your fee is tuition fee,
tuition fee is four installments,
then the concession is also tuition fee.
Okay?
Four installments will be given.
Yes, ma'am.
Okay?
Now, you have to make concessions.
For example,
the concession that I am making,
I am making staff card concessions.
Okay?
Here, you will define the name
of the concession that you are creating.
Then, the concession that you are creating,
which fee head is it on?
There is one option,
everyone's fee head is on our concession.
One fee head is on our concession.
Okay?
You will select according to your concession.
For example,
the staff card concession,
their annual fee is on that concession.
They have said that
they have 50% concession.
Like, all the fees,
the complete fees are 50%.
Okay?
So, you have two options,
percentage and flat.
I have talked about 50%.
So, I will use percentage,
and here,
I will list the percentage value.
Like, in sub-installment,
it is 50%.
Okay?
So, I have done 50 here.
In case,
concession is not in percentage,
that is,
it is in flat.
Flat means,
it is 5000 concessions
for first installment only.
It is not on anyone else.
Okay?
So, in that way,
you can flat according to your concession
and add that value.
Clear?
To create concession group,
you will add normal,
your concession group will be added.
Yes, ma'am.
staff can have concession,
like sibling concession.
Whatever is their criteria,
on the basis of that criteria,
your concession can be done.
Ma'am,
in this system,
by default,
this name,
like staff board,
we have typed it ourselves.
So, by default,
all the concessions
which are available,
they will come by default,
when you assign concession.
For example,
when I assign concession
then I will get that list,
that which concessions
we have made
the name of every entity
is very different.
Okay?
So, in that case,
when will this come?
We are defining it now.
Now,
the thing you are saying
that it is listed,
we are selecting it.
So, we are defining it now.
From here.
When the student
will be assigned,
then it will come.
For a drop down.
Okay?
One more thing,
most of the time
we do manual concessions also.
You must have seen
that many times
such concessions
are given.
Like,
the principal said,
give me 5,000 rupees.
Okay?
So, that is our manual concession.
That is,
we can give it at any cost.
It means,
it is up to the institute
to give it at any cost.
Okay?
We can give it at any cost.
So, such a concession
is also called
manual concession.
Okay?
I mean,
it is used in most of the entities
so that is why
I am telling you
to do manual concessions.
In the case of manual concessions
we keep all the head sticks
and we flat them
and do zero.
Why do we do this?
Because this is
such a concession group
in which
you don't know
when and how much concession
is to be given
to a student.
Okay?
This,
your fee clerk
or any person concerned
in the institute
will assign
their criteria.
So, in that case
we also make
a manual concession.
Okay?
When this happens,
when it is not defined
they have to give concessions
but they don't define
how much concessions
they have to give.
It varies
in every student's case.
Then manual concessions
are given.
Okay?
Okay ma'am.
Let me tell you
how it can be done.
Because if you see
the fee demand
then it is only
in the annual fees.
If it is not there
then the concession
will not be given.
Right?
When the concession
will also be given
as much as the amount
will be given.
Now here you have
the option
that is editable for you
means you can give
as much concessions
as you want according to you.
We call that
manual concession.
Okay?
Whatever remark you want to enter
you will enter the remark
and there is an option
we can upload the file
from here.
Like you must have seen
there is an application
on which
there is a signature
it is written
then that document
can be uploaded
corresponding to
this particular student.
If you save
then it will be saved.
Here you have
the confirmation
asking
that
we have received
They have received
the money
from the beginning.
That is why
they are giving it.
In this
you can see
concession.
If you click
then you will save.
Okay?
In this
you can see
what he is saying
For example
the fees
for this student
are all
the money
he has.
Okay?
And I am
assigning concessions
but we have received
it.
Do you understand?
After that
you are making concessions
so we are saying
that we will
to the extra fee
So you still have
to proceed
or not
He is saying that.
Do you understand?
For example
the amount.
Then
manually.
Student profiles and the
student interface open.
Assign route then a pop up
window.
Like
pick up point.
The amount.
Automatically.
Drop point.
Select different.
Installment.
Assign.
Transport.
System.
Automatically.
Transport.
Assign.
No more.
Okay.
That's all for today.
Ma'am, please share the recording.